[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so
much for all coming today.
I thoroughly enjoy
hosting these few talks,
but I must admit
today is definitely
one of my highlights.
I've been following "Deliciously
Ella" for some time,
and really looking forward
to hearing her story.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Ella Mills.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you for coming in today.
Can you please start by
telling us a bit about
how you came up with
"Delicious Ella," and why?
ELLA MILLS: First of
all, hi, everyone.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
I'm honored to be
in your offices.
So "Delicious Ella,"
it's a long story,
and I will keep it really
nice and short for you guys.
But I started it really
accidentally, back in 2012.
In 2011, I was at university,
and I got really unwell.
And I spent about four
months in that hospital,
and I was diagnosed
with a condition called
postural tachycardia syndrome,
which is quite a mouthful.
And it affects your
autonomic nervous system,
and that affected my
ability to control my heart
rate, my immune system,
blood pressure, digestion,
and lots of other things.
And so I spent most of
the following year in bed,
taking steroids and all
kinds of other medication.
And unfortunately, it didn't
really work very well for me,
and I still wasn't able
to kind of maintain
normal bodily functions.
And which meant I couldn't
really do anything.
And so I really struggled with
the physical side of that,
but I really struggled with
the mental side of that.
And the kind of isolation of it
and I had quite bad depression.
And I really hit my
personal rock bottom,
and I realized
that, to be honest,
I was taking all
this medication,
and I was relying on everybody
else to try to help me.
And I wasn't really doing
much to help myself.
And so I started googling,
as you do, as you guys do.
And I came across
lots of people who
had used diet and
lifestyles as ways
of managing all kinds
of different illnesses
and conditions, and I was
really interested in that.
And I thought that,
that was worth a try.
But I had kind of a couple
of major issues, which was
that I had no idea how to cook.
And I had no idea
what healthy food was.
So my grand plan was not going
to be executed very well.
And so-- and then,
the third thing
being the fact that I
was really struggling,
kind of with any
kind of motivation
or really interest
in life in general.
And so I decided
what I would do is
I'd kind of put these
things together,
and I would start
writing a blog.
Because then I could
channel some of my time
into that, rather than
watching the Kardashians,
and all the other
good stuff on repeat.
And I could learn how
to do food photography,
and I could learn
how to use a camera,
and I can learn all
about editing pictures,
and then also using a
blog, writing a blog.
And at the same time, I
would learn how to cook,
and I'd learn how to put
these meals together.
And the WordPress site needed
a name, and my name is Ella.
And I was about as
unimaginative as to think
that hopefully the
food will be delicious,
and that's "Deliciously Ella."
And people ask me all the
time where the name came from,
and I always want to come up
with a really clever, genius
reply.
And I'm just like no.
10 seconds of lack
of thought actually.
Great.
And so I started writing,
and, to be honest,
I was super skeptical
when I started.
And I had this image that
healthy food all meant
iceberg lettuce, and grated
carrots, and cucumbers
and that's kind of my
worst nightmare food,
actually still is.
And I didn't want it to be that.
And so I started writing,
and I started creating,
and I started playing around
the kitchen, experimenting,
and I really, really enjoyed it.
And so I was recording on this
online, and to start with,
my mom was definitely
my only reader.
And probably at her book club.
And then it started to grow,
and it grew really slowly
in the first six months.
I had 100,000 hits, but
in the second six months,
I had 900,000.
That was really interesting,
because I've never
tried to do anything with that.
And that was like
really organic growth
through friends and friends.
And there was a
map, and you could
see where people
were reading it from,
and it was no longer
kind of UK, America, then
sort of the rest of Europe.
It was suddenly
all these places,
like in the middle
of the Pacific.
I knew no one in my
mom's book club was that.
So it couldn't just
be them refreshing it.
And so there were really
people engaging with it,
and I was really enjoying it.
And it was starting to
really, really help me.
So I decided that I
would take it further,
and I started
doing social media.
Which is also great,
but on a personal level,
just inspired me
to keep cooking.
And I think there's always
such a link between anything
being sustainable and
it being enjoyable.
And the more I was doing,
and trying new things,
and getting better at it,
the more I enjoyed it.
And the more
sustainable it became.
And then when I started
doing social media,
that's when it started
really growing.
And then people said, oh do
you teach cooking classes?
And I was like, I have no
idea what I'm doing it.
In no shape or
form am I qualified
to teach a cooking class.
But I've always tried
to be a yes person,
and I thought,
yeah let's try it.
Why not?
And I found a kitchen an
Old Street that I rented,
and it's this really
sweet community kitchen.
But it's pretty random, because
there's this big kitchen,
and then in front of that
is this community center.
And it's filled with lots of
old people having their lunch,
and their having
their fish and chips.
And I was like come on
through, come to make kale
with me in the back.
And so I did that for about
six months, and it was great.
And actually, it was the first
time that I realized that--
I guess from my own
personal perspective,
the power of the internet
in what I was doing.
Because they'd sell
out within 24 hours
each time, just through
putting them on my channels,
which was amazing.
And so then, after I
did that, I decided
I'd test it further, because
the cooking classes were
quite small.
It was 10 to 14
people in a class.
So although that was
great, it wasn't really
a great way of
seeing whether or not
this was a more viable
business, and such
a small number of people.
So I decided that I
would do an app next,
because I felt that
while blogs are great,
and it's been an amazing
place for me to start,
but they're quite annoying.
If you want to make
dinner, you don't
want to have to scroll
through 30 pages of something
to find your idea.
So I thought I would do a
really simple recipe app.
And so I created that,
thinking that would
be a really long
time investment,
and it would take a long
time to earn the money back.
And it was the polar
opposite, and overnight it
went to number one in food
and drink in the iTunes store
in the UK and the
US, and it stayed
in the top three of the UK food
and drink really ever since,
and that was 2014.
So that's been amazing.
And then after that came out,
and that did really well,
someone approached
me to write a book.
Which was also hilarious,
because I was like, again,
I don't really know if
I'm qualified to do this.
But in the spirit of
saying yes, I said yes.
And wrote my first
book, and that
was something, where again
I remember saying to my mom,
what do you think about this?
Do you think this will work?
And she was like, yeah, I bet
you can sell 1,000 copies.
And I was like, yeah we can
definitely sell 1,000 copies,
and we're now about over
1.2 million copies later.
So I'm proud that we finally
exceeded her expectations.
And we turned 20
languages, and it's
been in New York Times Best
Sellers, and since then,
two other number one
best selling cookbooks.
I met my husband a couple of
months after the book came out,
and it was one of those
things that, it was amazing.
And it took off overnight,
and that was incredible.
But it kind of have gone from
being a small, niche thing
that I was doing at my
parents' kitchen, on my time,
on my schedule.
And suddenly it was out
there, and the press
are talking about
you, and people
start talking about
you, rather than to you.
From a personal perspective,
that was quite a strange thing.
I'd also really struggled
with self-esteem,
and self-confidence, and
everything while I was sick.
And I'm not sure
I was completely,
really in the right
place for all this
to necessarily be happening.
And I was quite
overwhelmed by it.
And although it was
really exciting,
the opportunities
were amazing, I
was quite anxious about it all.
And I met Matt, who's my husband
and our business partner,
as well.
And we started talking
about it, and then
we started work-- this
is the longest answer
to your question, I'm sorry.
SPEAKER 1: That's
OK, that's fine.
ELLA MILLS: Talking forever--
but we started talking
about it, because I
was feeling like i was
quite outside my control.
And it just snowballed,
and he, a bit
older, and had been doing
business development
and finance, and so had a
much better understanding
of how things actually
work than I did.
I just love cooking, I love
food, I love communicating,
I love visuals.
And I was so enjoying
creating the brand,
and doing all the events
and everything around it.
But I didn't really
understand spreadsheets
or any of the practical
stuff, and so Matt and I
started working together.
And he really drove the
business development forward,
and I stayed working really on
the creative side and the brand
side.
And that's been
amazing, and we've
decided we'd take it further,
and see whether or not
we could take what was
so successful online,
and make it work on something
a little bit more tangible.
So we opened our first
deli site in December 2015,
so just over a year ago.
And that was hilarious, again
that was a real experiment,
and we wanted to
take the cheapest
rent that we could
find in London
that was vaguely accessible.
It's on a small street
called Seymour place, which
is-- we always say
Marylebone, it's really not.
It's Edgware Road, it's
like prime shisha-ville.
And that's not really much
footfall on that street,
but the rents was
really, really good.
By a long way, the
best thing we'd found.
And its like a seven minute
walk from Selfridges,
it's a three minute
walk from Marble Arch,
so it's a good location,
but it just doesn't
have a huge amount of footfall.
And neither of us
had ever run anything
like this before
in our life, and we
didn't have the
money, at that point,
to hire any managers who
knew better than we did.
And so we opened
it, and in four days
we had like 80 RQs out the door.
We were like, go away.
[LAUGHTER]
We don't know what
to do with you.
But it was amazing.
And so for the first two
months we were in there,
we literally had a system
where I would do the tills.
And so you'd come in,
and I could talk to you,
and learn a little bit more
about you, and what you wanted,
and what you were interested in,
what you thought of the food.
And Matt was the cleaner, and
he cleaned everyone's plates.
And so he could find
out what your thoughts
were after you had it.
And, although it was like-- it
was a completely insane couple
of months, because the same
time I was finishing my book,
and then started promotion
for my next book,
and started a book tour,
and doing those events.
But then we will
also like managers,
we were doing everything.
And after 3 and
1/2 weeks, our chef
quit, because she said
she wanted to Barcelona,
and she didn't want
to be a chef anymore.
And I was like--
Matt was really
sick with the fly,
and I was standing on
the street outside,
just watching all these people
queuing up, and I'm like,
you're joking.
So anyway, then we
started hiring people,
and that's when things changed.
And that was really amazing.
But it did, of
course, small sites,
so we really quickly decided
on finding our next site, which
we opened mid last year.
And then we'll open our next
site in a couple of weeks time.
So the second one is
on Weighhouse Street,
which is just where
crossrails are going by,
up on street tube.
And then, the third
site is in Herne Hill.
It's all funded, and that's
it, really, on the site front.
That's kind of what we want to
use as our marketing suite, is
places where people can come
in, they can feel the brand,
they can touch the brand.
But where we're really
scaling is in product.
So we launched
our first product,
which is our energy balls.
Which is the most popular
recipe on the blog,
and had been in the delis, and
we launched that last August.
And we're really lucky to
have the platform that we did,
and people were really
receptive to it,
so we've gone into
2,500 stores already
with an enough for 6 months.
So we're in places
like Starbucks,
as well as Waitrose,
Sainsbury's, Holland
and Barrett, WHsmith's, Ocardo.
And then places like Selfridges
and Fortnum and Mason.
And then we've got
two more recipes
that we're adding
next week, and then
a whole new range that sits
outside out snacking, coming
in August.
So that's the longest
answer to your question.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
ELLA MILLS: But that's how
"Deliciously Ella" came about,
and what it is now.
SPEAKER 1: You've been busy.
So going back to your
diet, before you changed it
to more of a plant-based diet,
what were you eating before?
ELLA MILLS: To be
honest, I didn't really
think much about it before.
It was just something--
I'd always enjoyed food,
and if you said to me,
Ella, do you want to come to
this delicious restaurant,
I made you this delicious thing.
I'd be really appreciative
and really enjoy it,
but it wasn't
something that I really
would think of outside of that.
And I ate anything
and everything,
but I also never
really connected
what you ate, and the
impact on how you feel,
and your energy levels,
and things like that.
So yeah, people would be
like, oh you are what you eat.
And I was like, well, I
eat a lot gummy bears.
So I know I never
really believed it.
And then, as I said reading,
and learning, and understanding
more about how the
human body works,
and then all about the
different compositions
of different foods, and the
reasons why it would make
sense to eat things
like broccoli.
I started to have an
appreciation for it,
and that's really where
my interests came.
So it was a really big change.
And also as a student
when I changed terms.
So although-- my
mom gets so upset,
because I'm doing interviews,
and they're like, so
did you eat really
badly beforehand?
And I'd be like,
yeah, it wasn't great.
And she'll read it, and be like,
I just sound like the worst
mother ever.
All you talk about
Haribo, like that is not
the only thing I fed you.
But I was so resistant
to fruit and vegetables.
Her best story ever
to tell everyone,
now that I do what I do, is
that-- there's four of us,
and the other three was
so much better than I was.
And I would refuse to
eat basically any fruit
and vegetable, but
every now and again when
she'd get really
upset about it, I'd
be like, no, no I like bananas,
you know I like bananas.
She's like, well, then eat one.
So I would chop it up, and
I'd just slice it really,
really thinly.
And I make concentric
circles on a big plate,
and then I'd do eeny,
meeny, miny, moe.
But it wouldn't be
like eeny, meeny, miny,
moe I will eat you, it was
eeny, meeny, miny, moe,
I will not eat you.
And then that would
go on another plate
to make circles until
there was one piece left,
and then I would eat that.
So it was a resistance game
[LAUGHTER]
It was like an hour and
a half to eat a banana.
And she tells the story to
anyone and everyone now,
she loves it so much.
And yeah, it was a
really big change,
going from someone who's
eating like everything.
From just sandwiches, and
bagels, and a lot of ice cream,
and candy, and cereal, but
just never kind of putting--
I'm sure I got my
five a day like once
a month, like five a
month, rather than a day.
And I just wasn't really
connecting to fresh food,
and I never really thought
about the impact of it.
So then, I think everyone
was really confused,
and I said, oh I'm really
interested in a vegan diet.
And everyone was like, but
you don't eat vegetables,
so you'll die.
[LAUGHTER]
What are you going to eat?
Just like plain
pasta, and that's it.
So I was like, I should
really think about that.
My mom was like, oh gosh,
where is this going to go?
And I told my then
boyfriend-- who is great,
but who isn't always reflected
that well in the story--
that I was going to
start a food blog.
And he was like, that's
the worst idea I ever
heard, you don't cook, you're
not interested in food,
like why would anybody
ever read that?
It is so ironic now that it's
had over 100 million hits,
and people really like it.
But, it wasn't something
that I'd really connected to
before, it was, from a
positive perspective,
it was a really,
really big change.
And it was hard as well,
because I didn't really
know how to cook.
And so the first things I
cooked were pretty gross.
And one night-- I didn't
really know anything
about quinoa and kale,
let alone almond milk,
and so to start with I was
like, OK, well, porridge
seems like an obvious
swap from cereals.
Because I was mainly eating
Cheerios-type cereals.
And I didn't really know
about almond milk and things
like that, so I was just
eating basically gruel.
It was just oats and
water, not very nice.
And things like that, so it
took me a while to really start
to enjoy it, because I
think enjoying something
is so key to sustainability.
And what I was
cooking, I don't think
anyone would have
found enjoyable,
for the first few months.
SPEAKER 1: So what
point, and which dish,
did you taste and think,
wow, this is really nice,
and I can carry
on eating this Way
ELLA MILLS: Yeah, I think
it was probably just
after a couple of months, once
I was feeling a little bit more
comfortable with it.
And it was just little things,
but I think it wasn't until I
had a grasp on the whole thing.
Even the sweet things, like
I'm a big fan of saying,
I don't think you should
ever feel deprived.
So I think if you do
want to something sweet,
you should try and
have something sweet,
rather than like
always suppressing it,
and then just been craving
it so much that you
have like seven bags of Haribo.
So I didn't really know how to
do that, I didn't love fruit,
and I'd never come across
things like dates before,
and so I just hadn't really
put two and two together.
But once I started
doing that, and I
started learning to make things,
like the energy bills and stuff
like that, that made a
really big difference.
Because then, if I
wanted something sweet,
I could have something
sweet, and that just
changed the whole enjoyability
factor of everything.
SPEAKER 1: And so,
as well as your diet,
what else were you changing
with your lifestyle?
ELLA MILLS: I guess it's
quite cheesy, isn't it?
But it was like a kind of--
I'm a big believer, that
I think feeling good.
I think diet plays a
really big role in it,
but I don't think it's
the be-all and end-all,
and I think sometimes we
put too much pressure on it.
And I think feeling good comes
from every aspect of your life,
from managing things
like exercises.
By exercise, I don't necessarily
mean going to a boot camp,
but just like moving and walking
and kind of getting outside.
And managing stress levels,
and sleep, and relationships,
both with yourself and
with the people around you.
And I just kind of
generally creating a more,
I guess more positive
space around you,
makes such a big difference.
And so I guess I
try to kind of shape
and focus on all those
different aspects of my life.
So I got into things
like meditation and yoga,
which is like the
most cheesy thing
ever for like a health writer.
SPEAKER 1: And so you've
touched on earlier,
when did you notice that
"Deliciously Ella" started
to get more of a following
than you expected?
And why do you think that was?
Why do you think the
masses turned to your blog.
ELLA MILLS: Yeah, I think--
I'd love to take
credit for everything,
but I think timing is such
a big element of anything.
I think so much success
comes down to timing,
and I think it was
something I think people--
there's been so many things,
you know all the things
you read every time about sugar,
everyone talking about, well,
now you're 10 a day, the impact
of the Mediterranean diet,
there's so much.
And then at the same time having
like a global obesity crisis,
and all the problems of
having NHS, and things
like the cost of
type 2 diabetes.
And all these-- lots of
lifestyle-related illnesses
and things that
we're having that's
getting a lot of
attention, I think.
And also the food industry
is quite confusing,
it's become quite complicated,
things about crisis of food.
And I think the debate had
become quite intense around it,
so I think people were becoming
very interested in the way they
ate, and aware of how much
sugar, how much salt was
in everything.
And so but I don't think
there was much in it.
I mean, when I decided I
wanted to change my diet,
and I was really
interested in this,
I went online and
went on Amazon.
And I was trying to
find some inspiration.
I would never, ever have
done "Deliciously Ella"
if that day I'd found
some good inspiration.
And I would never be
sitting here today,
because I would've
just used what I found.
I didn't find anything.
The only book that I
found was a paperback,
basically just like a novel,
there was no pictures in it.
And then there was
things like almond pate,
and I was like, oh come on.
That's like all those
kind of old stereotypes
of vegetarianism, it's
like super hippie.
Yeah, you do yoga,
and meditate, and you
don't shave your armpits,
and eat almond pate.
It's not exactly very
aspirational, or fun,
or exciting.
And it was just that
there were no pictures.
There was just nothing
to make it engaging.
And yeah, that
was my inspiration
for starting "Deliciously
Ella," I just
didn't feel like there
was that much there.
And I think-- you
read all these things.
I was reading all these
books and all these studies,
and I was so interested
in the science,
find it in the nutrition,
and understanding
how the body works, and why
it would make sense for--
like a car, so give
it the right fuel.
But I was finding I'd get
to the end of the book,
and then sometimes it'd
have recipes in it.
It that literally like
kale wrapped in chard
with a cucumber stick inside
it, it was just so healthy,
and it was so green.
And this was talking
to someone that
ate loads of burgers,
and pizza, and ice cream,
and I could not go from burger,
and pizza, and ice cream
to raw kale three times a day.
It's just too much.
And I felt like there
was really a space,
or like a middle
ground, that was
trying to take this idea
of eating your five a day,
eating your ten a day,
eating more fiber,
celebrating vegetables.
But in a way that
was actually as
simple as possible,
as quick as possible,
and hopefully delicious.
And making it just
a bit more fun.
And I always say that
that's my number one
aim, is I want to
make vegetables cool.
You don't need to
be a vegan, you
don't need to be a vegetarian,
you don't to be an anything.
It's not about
labeling yourself,
it's just about trying to have a
bit more of this kind of stuff.
And it's never going to
happen if we don't change
the way we think about it.
I read that-- well, everyone
would have read all the stuff
about your ten a
day, and then I read
this really interesting
article in The Guardian
like a week later.
The journalist was like, I
tried to do my ten a day,
it was the most miserable
thing I've ever done.
And he was literally just eating
a big carrot out of a bag,
because he was like, I
don't know how to do it.
He ate like seven clementines
one day, and he just--
and I understand it.
And I think everyone's the
same, if we don't change
our mindset with how we
put a plate together,
it's never gonna change.
And you know, you go to so
many amazing restaurants,
where the food is so good,
the chef's so talented,
and you eat amazing,
appetizing dish after another.
And then you get to the
bottom, and it's just
spinach and broccoli.
Like is anybody here excited
about steamed broccoli?
I mean I'm not, and
I love vegetables.
Like it's not gonna
get people excited.
And that's why I realize,
and I think that.
From what I understand,
that's been the success
of "Deliciously Ella,"
is trying to give people
a way of eating broccoli,
sauteed in garlic and chili,
with sesame and
tahini, or something
like that, that actually makes
you maybe want to have it.
And that's why I'm
saying, you only
need to eat broccoli--
absolutely not.
But if you are ever going
to include it in your diet,
in a sustainable way,
it's got to switch
and it's got to be enjoyable.
And I think there was such
a lack of that around.
And I think that's
been the success of it.
And I think the story
helped, like I've always
tried to be as open and honest
as I could be with anybody
and everyone about
my own journey,
and why I got
interested in this.
And I think that helps,
because sometimes again, you
read things and you're
like, I could never do that.
Because it feels like people
have been doing it forever
and it's quite intimidating.
And like I was really
a Haribo person,
and I think it's the idea of,
if you could do it, I can do it.
SPEAKER 1: So, you're going
to come up with a vegan
version of Haribo then?
ELLA MILLS: No, I think
there's enough people doing
things like that already.
SPEAKER 1: So then what are your
tips on being an entrepreneur
and growing a business?
ELLA MILLS: The best
piece of advice anybody
ever gave me, which
really resonated with me,
was to be an optimist.
Which always seems like
probably a silly answer
to obviously such a big
question, which obviously does
involve important things,
like your cash flow
and things like that.
But actually, I think that when
you're starting something out,
which is going to
be 3,000 problems,
and you're going to be
really small compared
to everybody else.
We're really a small
business, we're a small team,
we have a small budget.
And then we're dealing
with big businesses,
with big budgets, and big
teams who don't always
care about the small businesses,
although people claim they do.
And how do you go out--
and not take out the
big stakeholders.
Like how do you go and compete
with a company that's already
been trading for 12 years?
And they do now have a
bit of a marketing budget,
people do know how they are.
And I think being an
optimist is so important,
because you've got
to always think
that you can find a solution.
I think you have to be a
bit naive and a bit crazy
in lots of ways, because
if someone had sat me down
and said like, let
me just list you,
maybe like the 12
biggest problems you're
going to have in the next year.
I would've been like, OK,
I'm not going to do this.
I'm going to keep
writing my blog,
because that is so much easier.
And I'll do collaborations
with this and I'll do that,
and maybe I'll license my name,
but I'm not doing it myself.
But actually having done it, I
wouldn't do it any other way.
But it's so scary, and there's
so many different things
to deal with.
And even things, like I
said, after 3 and 1/2 weeks
of trading, we still don't--
just beginning to find our
feet, and then the chef's
like, no I'm moving
to Barcelona,
I don't really want
to do this anymore.
And you have to be like, bye.
I'm not going to have
a mental breakdown,
I'm just going to try
to find a solution.
And there's just been so
many things like that.
Like the day before we were
meant to leave for a wedding,
and I had to go on my
book tour in America,
and then we were
going to a wedding.
So basically, I was not
really here for a month,
and that same chef, who
was tricky, was leaving.
And she just
couldn't be bothered
for the last couple of days.
And so she got to the point
that she literally sent--
there was a third of
the food we were meant
to have for that day, and
there was one dessert,
we normally have eight.
And someone had misread
the recipe, instead
of it being oats, it
was coconut chips.
They picked up the desserts,
and the bottom ledge
went on the floor.
And I was like, right.
So we've got on
Saturday, our busiest day
of trading, we really
need these numbers,
because we're about to pay a
deposit for our second site.
And we have no food,
and we have no dessert,
because the only dessert,
the bottom just falls off.
And you just have to find a
way to be so positive and so
creative about it.
And I think-- yeah, we've
gone from a team of 44 people
to 60 people in 18 months, and
that comes with so many growing
pains.
Like we're trying
to find an office,
and we've been
outbid three times.
Even when we got into
legal, someone comes
and they just have that bit
more money, and we're like,
we need an office, our
lease is up in three weeks,
we don't have a space.
But we're small, we
can't afford to be like,
yeah we'll give you that extra
15,000 pounds, we don't have.
And so I think, just trying
to always have a smile,
and always be like,
yeah that's a solution,
rather than get sucked
into the problem.
Because as soon as you get
sucked into the problem,
you're gonna have five other
problems in the same day.
Even if they're minor ones,
they're still problems.
And so trying to
just be optimistic,
and always feeling
like there's an answer.
And that's being my number one.
And That I think
the second one is
people, and recognizing
where your strengths are,
and where they're not.
I was so young when I
started my business,
I'm the first person
to acknowledge that.
And as much as I feel like I
know "Deliciously Ella" better
than anybody, and therefore
I think our audience
better than everybody.
And that is a big
audience, and I
think I have a good
understanding of the space,
and I love creating the
brand and the communication
and everything.
I've never worked
in an FMCG business
before, I don't know it.
And Matt had worked
in finance, and he'd
worked in business
development, and he'd
done lots of other things,
but neither did he.
And so actually, going
out and to hire--
so we went and hired
this amazing guy
called Dan, who was the head of
innovation at Innocent Drinks.
And he came to be the MD of
that side of our business,
and that was the best
decision we've ever made.
And it's quite scary, because
you're bringing someone in.
And I've done it all on my
own up until this point.
And I was like, wait what,
now you tell me what to do,
that's strange.
It's my name, it's my face.
But actually it's the best thing
that we could have ever done,
because he has experience,
understanding, and knowledge
that we can't even begin
to pretend that we have.
And we've now been
doing this 18 months,
I can't compare to 15
years of experience.
And so I think trying to
take as much of a step
back and get the best
people that you can get,
I think that makes the
world of difference.
Because Matt always says,
which people always laugh at,
but I think it's trying to be
the dumbest person in the room.
Like surround yourself
with the best people
that you can learn from, and
that you can get better from,
and that can help you be
the better version of you,
and therefore your company
be the better version
of your company.
Rather than saying like,
no this is my thing,
and really holding on to that.
SPEAKER 1: Have
there been any points
where you thought, no I
really want to go this way,
and you've been persuaded
to go a different way?
Or you stuck t your values.
ELLA MILLS: Yeah, well,
when Matt and I started
working together,
we made an agreement
that with any big
decision we would
both have to agree on it fully.
And if one person didn't 100%
agree, then we wouldn't do it.
So we've had a couple of
moments with things like that,
especially with finding
different sites.
And we were gonna open a site
in a big department store,
and then Matt changed
his mind about an hour
before we were meant to sign.
And I completely
disagreed with him.
In retrospect, he was right,
and I was definitely not.
And actually having a
partner in that sense
is great, because
I think sometimes
it helps give you a new
perspective on things.
But, yeah, and
actually honestly,
like on a personal level,
that was a big ego thing.
Because obviously I had done
it on my own for a while.
I was like this is my
thing, this is my name,
this is my face.
And to just take a step back
and let other people have
their opinions that can override
yours was quite a strange--
the first couple of months
of that, was quite strange,
it was quite an
adjustment for me.
But it's definitely
made everything
that we do so much better.
SPEAKER 1: And do you
have to take a step back
when you get home,
and say, well, OK,
that's the business side,
this is now our relationship.
Or do you still talk about
business over dinner?
ELLA MILLS: That's the
only thing we talk about.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, really?
[LAUGHTER]
ELLA MILLS: We have a
business, watch this face,
I know what's gonna happen
with this relationship.
I don't know, it's
one of those things,
like I feel every now and again
you just get an opportunity.
And we've done a lot
in the last year,
and I think more
than a lot of people
who have a lot more
experience than we do,
being like you're doing too
much, it's not a good idea.
But I just-- it's
so rare in life
that you get to-- we're
really lucky people
want to work with us now, we get
invited to do amazing things.
And I just think
we're mad to say no.
I don't think--
And also , when Matt and I
first started really taking it
further into the production,
the sites, and things like that,
"Deliciously Ella"
was doing very well.
Sure, it was the fastest
selling debut cookbook ever,
and we were growing
really, really quickly,
and people were
talking about us,
and we were in this
magazine and that.
And that was great, but
that gets quite boring
after a while.
And if we hadn't have
developed it further,
I don't think "Deliciously
Ella" would still be
doing as well as it was today.
I'm not sure I'd necessarily
be sitting here with you guys.
And so actually
again, it was one
of those things of being
like, here's the opportunity.
If we want to take it
further, we just got to do it.
And it also, if we don't do
it now, someone else will.
And the cards were all
in our favor to do it,
so it was just a moment
of running with it.
And I think we said quite early
on that we weren't going to--
and I really respect
everyone who does do it--
but we were like,
we're going to give up
on the concept of
a work/life balance
for the next couple of years.
And just say it's
work/life integration.
Like I love what I
do, Matt loves what he
does, like we love our company.
And we've but
everything into it,
like our house is
mortgaged against it,
we've borrowed everything
we could from our parents,
every penny both of us has
earned is in the business.
Like if we go bust,
we're completely screwed,
and our parents will
be very unhappy.
So everything's in it,
and I think we just said,
it's one of those
things you just, you've
got to take the opportunity.
And if it doesn't
work-- and it's just
come above everything,
and that's weired,
because obviously
your social life
is like very much
in the back foot.
Not sure the last time
I saw really friends.
But it's just what it is, and
it's so fun, it's so exciting.
And how many times
in life are you
ever gonna get an
opportunity where you can
hire 60 people in 12 months?
We're so young, and to be able
to start a business like that,
and to have Starbucks
take a meeting with you,
and say we're gonna stock your
products when they're not even
on the shelf yet.
Like it's so incredible.
And I think we both
felt like we would
be mad to not run with it.
SPEAKER 1: I'm gonna
ask one more question,
and then I'm going to
hand it over to you guys.
Sorry.
So what's been the highlight?
ELLA MILLS: So many things.
Honestly, I think our teams are,
like for me, is the highlight.
They're just amazing.
And I feel like I've learned
so much from the people
that we work with
over the last year,
and it's been the most amazing
learning experience for me.
And like being able-- yeah,
I find it really inspiring.
So on a personal level,
that's probably it.
On, I guess on a
professional thing,
in terms of what we've done,
I think going into Starbucks
is a real highlight.
Although people then said
that we were selling out,
and were a bit upset
online for a little bit.
But to be able to take
a a healthy thing,
and be able to make it
that mainstream is amazing,
and something that I
think we, as a company,
we're really, really proud of.
And not many people get
the opportunity to do that,
and so to have that was kind
of a real testament to how
far the company has come
and what we we created.
So that was incredible.
And then I think,
the other one, was
that we did Wilderness Festival
last summer with the deli,
and we did this big pop-up deli.
And I think-- we weren't
really sure how it would go,
and we did 1.5 metric
tons of food in 36 hours.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
ELLA MILLS: It was
a really intense.
That was the-- but it was
amazing, it was so cool.
And to have done that
much food, and people
would come and be like, why
is there no avocado toast?
And I'm like, we've done
50 kilos of avocado toast
in an hour.
We did not see that coming,
it's a very small town.
And that was really
amazing again,
just because I think
that sometimes you
have those moments where you
realize how well something's
doing.
And when you get so in
the nitty-gritty of it,
sometimes you get a bit snowed
under with the problems.
Implementation in the
store, development
with this, or a complication
with this, or building
work delays or something.
But actually when
you stand there,
and you see queues that
don't stop for 12 hours,
and getting through that
much food from something
that's not even a third of the
size of this room in 36 hours.
That many people wanting
it, it was just amazing.
So that was--
I really-- Allen,
who's our chef,
he's the most amazing man.
I was like, please don't
quit, just keep going.
And then we go to the end, he
was like, I need to go home.
And I was like, yep!
Thank you.
But yeah, that was amazing.
SPEAKER 1: Fantastic.
All right, I'm just going
to grab some microphones,
and I'll pass these
out to everybody.
So who would like to
ask some questions?
Wonderful.
AUDIENCE: Hi, just
a quick question,
in terms of how
much it's affected
your health, from having an
illness and sort of helping it
through food.
It seems that--
I hear a lot of
different conditions,
and how much food helps
people, but you're
given medication when
you go to the doctors.
Have you done anything-- tried
to do anything down that route,
in terms of changing the
perception from the health
side?
ELLA MILLS: Yeah,
it's a great question.
I mean, no is the short answer.
But just as more of an answer
is that it's so, so tricky.
It's a very emotional,
complicated topic for people.
And I think also that
everybody is different,
and it's really hard to prove
science behind a lot of this.
A lot of it is anecdotal,
and anecdotes aren't enough
unfortunately.
So it's really, really tricky.
But at the moment,
my interest is just
trying to give people the tools,
that if they are interested,
that they may actually do it.
And they'll enjoy
it, and therefore
hopefully keep doing it.
And I get e-mails and notes
from people every day,
and it's made such a
big impact in their life
for very different reasons.
I meet people all the time.
But as I said, that's
always anecdotal.
I think it's one of
those things that'll
be interesting to see how
we go, because I think
more and more of
those people who
are very interested in this, and
who see real success with it.
But then there's
more and more people
who are very resistant to
anything that kind of changes
the status quo, or that's
a little bit controversial.
And so I think there's
a bit of a head-to-head
that I'm sure that
we're going to have,
maybe in a decade's time.
There are a lot of
people who really
want to push forward in I guess
a slightly more holistic sense.
And that's not to dis--
doctors are the most amazing
people on the planet,
like if I'm in a car accident
I don't want a nutritionist.
But I do think there's an
element of working together,
that we miss out so
much of the time.
And is so often is not noted.
It's like the two
remain so separate.
I took medication
for three years
until I felt like I was
strong enough to come off it.
And it was 100% the right
thing for me to keep doing,
rather than me being like,
oh I'm not going to take it,
I'm just going to eat kale.
Like I wasn't in a position
for that to be enough.
So I think it's going to be
interesting to see how it plays
out, because I do think there
are more and more people
who feel very, very
passionate about both sides
of the argument.
But I think that it will
change as people do so,
but I think that's
also by education,
or more open collaboration
between the side of nutrition
and conventional medicine.
Because at the moment,
they're so separate.
And so there either needs
to be more education,
in terms of doctor
training, where
that includes more nutrition.
Or patients need to have
much easier access to experts
and people in that field, who
can assist them side by side.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So my first question is, you've
hired 60 people in the last 12
months, are you still hiring?
ELLA MILLS: Yeah we--
much, much, much slower now.
That was almost all
within six months.
So now, I think--
well, we're opening
another site,
and then we're doing
a big two month
pop-up on Liverpool Street.
So we'll hire quite a
few people around that,
and we'll expand our
kitchen quite a lot.
We're doing a lot more
catering and events,
and things like that.
So that's quite a big
growth in that area.
But I think within
the office scene,
there will probably be about
another eight to 10 people
that we've earmarked,
that we want
to hire over the next
three to six months.
But so no, it won't keep
growing at that rate,
but I think probably
by then of the year,
it will probably
be just over 80.
AUDIENCE: OK, Interesting
And my other question is--
I'm a firm believer of what
you do, I'm really passionate.
I stopped eating sugar,
and dairy, and yeast,
and a lot of things.
But what I feel
is like socially,
I feel like I'm
high maintenance.
I go into a restaurant with
friends, and it's like,
does this have this or this?
And it sort of stops
me from wanting to go.
I sort of feel like
eating at home,
and then going to
see my friends.
Like, no I've already
eaten, like play cool.
Do you know what I mean.
Have you been in that situation?
How did you deal with it?
ELLA MILLS: Yeah, I
think that it is tricky.
I totally agree with
you, it's obviously
something I feel very
passionately about,
in terms of more natural food.
But it's not always that easy
when you're out and about.
And for me when I was getting
started, I was much more like,
I was like, I'll eat at
home and I'll come join you.
And then as I got
better, and I felt
like everything was
a bit more stable,
I've relaxed on it more.
And so I'd probably
eat most of the time.
But then if I'm out for
dinner two nights a week,
then I'll just be
out for dinner,
and I'll do the best I can.
But I'll also enjoy
it, and go back
to my green juice
in the morning.
And yeah, try and find
that kind of balance.
And I guess, for me, and I think
it's different for everyone,
but trying to find
that balance that
makes you happy physically,
but also mentally.
And I found sometimes
I was sitting there,
and I was like, oh
just one more question.
AUDIENCE: And you
felt like judged?
ELLA MILLS: Yeah, and I
was a bit embarrassed,
and it was just a
bit complicated.
And what I was getting started,
like each thing that I had,
had such a big impact on me,
because I had a problem called
mast cell activation.
It's about your
mast cells, which
is involved in
allergic reactions,
and I was having allergic
reactions to things
that I wasn't allergic to.
So basically
anything that wasn't
like super, super
plain, like soy sauce,
like all those
little things, which
are so often in
any kitchen, they
were causing loads of problems.
And you go on holiday,
and you'd want
to be really excited about
it, and after two days
I was just so much pain.
And my stomach hurt so
much, I felt so ill,
that I had to be so difficult.
Whereas now that I've
stabilized so much more,
four or five years later,
I find that much easier.
So I'd rather like relax
a couple of nights,
just enjoying myself, and not
be too weird with my friends.
And then kind of take it into my
own hands the rest of the time.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very
much for your talk.
I follow your Instagram page,
and I really, really love it.
And I notice that
sometimes you post
like yoga photos of like
headstands and things
like that.
So I was wondering, has exercise
played a role in your recovery?
And to what extent do you
think your lifestyle and food
diet impacts your well-being
and exercise routine?
ELLA MILLS: Yes, so
what I said earlier,
like I think that
everything's really connected.
And I think feeling good
comes from a whole mix
of different things.
And I think exercise
is important.
When I was getting better,
my doctor was doing a study,
and he did a nine
month exercise program
with lots of different of
his patients, and I did it.
And that was really amazing.
And it started off
literally two minutes
on one of those reclined bikes.
And I stopped for like
three hours afterwards.
And then each week you'd
go up by a minute or so,
and then after three months, we
went onto a normal bike, rather
than a reclined bike.
And then after
another three months,
or six months from
the beginning,
we went onto a cross-trainer,
and built up from that.
And by the end of the nine
months, it was 45 minutes.
Slow, but like 45 minutes
on a cross-trainer.
And that was really important,
I think, for my recovery.
Now I find exercise plays
a big role mentally for me.
Just because I find there's
a lot going on, and managing
stress, I find exercise is
my best way of doing it.
Just because I feel like
it's the easiest way to kind
of offload quite a lot, and
just like be quiet for an hour
or so.
No phone, no email, or anything,
and the rest of the time I
find that quite impossible.
And I notice the weeks
where I don't exercise,
I go a little bit crazy.
Just like a tiny bit.
AUDIENCE: Well, first
of all, thank you
for your books and your
Instagram, I love them.
And I made the mistake of giving
my mom the book for Christmas,
and now she constantly WhatsApps
me pictures of protein bowls.
And I'm like, I get
it, you can cook.
I just had a question, there's
like a lot of negative press
recently around
clean eating, and it
feels like a bit of
an attack on like--
I'm not sure if
you were mentioned,
but specifically people like
Hemsley Hemsley, and a lot
of people in the space.
And I wanted to know if
you had any views on it,
or whether you
actively spoke out,
trying to counter
their argument,
or whether you
just left it alone.
ELLA MILLS: Yeah, I guess.
Yeah, so I tried to
mostly leave that alone,
just because I think
that sometimes when
people have an
opinion, it's easier
to let people have an opinion.
But I think it's complicated,
because it's like anything,
you've got to find
what works for you.
And I'm a big believer that
there's no one size fits all.
And that you should take
inspiration from places,
but then your lifestyle's
different than everyone else's
lifestyles.
So you need to take
inspiration, and then
make it work for you in
whatever capacity that is.
And I know nothing should
be taken to an extreme.
But it's tricky,
because just because you
find an interesting
way to eat broccoli,
it doesn't mean you should
only ever broccoli again.
Likewise, like a
great baking book,
you should know to
not only eat cake.
And it's just quite complicated.
And I think the thing
with that debate
is that it kind of missed that.
But also from my perspective,
if somebody-- sometimes
will say to me, so do you
never have anything else?
And I'm like, yeah, sure.
Sometimes I'll be out for
dinner and I'll try this
or I'll try that.
But that's not what
"Deliciously Ella" is about.
"Deliciously Ella" is
trying to give people
a way of eating broccoli,
cauliflower, and chickpeas,
to be excited about them.
No one needs another way to
be excited about a burger,
like everyone has done it.
Like no one needs another way
to be excited about chocolate
cake, it's done.
Everyone already eats chocolate
cake, and cookies, and chips,
and burgers, and pizza,
and pasta, and they're cool
and they're socially acceptable.
And there's 1,001
restaurants serving them,
and 3 trillion cookbooks
dealing with them.
No one needs me to share a
picture of a bite of this
that I had, it's not relevant.
And what I think is frustrating,
is that's why I'm trying to do.
And I think that's what the
other people you mentioned
are trying to do, is
trying to give people
a way of eating these foods.
To me, it's a ridiculous
concept to print newspapers
that you should
eat your ten a day,
and yet not change anything.
Because nobody is going to
even get close to doing that,
if restaurant
menus don't change,
if education doesn't change,
if the way that we think
about food doesn't change.
And it's really ironic, to
me, to print all this stuff
about how much it's going to
lessen your chances of getting
this disease, and this
disease, and this disease.
And yet give nobody the
tools to actually implement
what you're saying.
And that's to me, is
what's frustrating.
I do believe that everyone does
what they want, and I'm not--
I don't think you should ever
feel guilty for what you do.
And if you want to go and enjoy
burger and pizza on a Friday
night, go ahead.
But you should also
eat more broccoli,
and you're not going
to do that if you
don't get the recipes for it.
I think the eat clean
thing completely
missed that whole point.
Like no one needs help
making burgers cool,
but they do need help
making cauliflower cool,
And I'm sure you guys saw that
KFC advert that just came out,
they're doing the same thing.
And it's like, if we keep
making fun of these foods,
no one is going to eat them.
And we need to talk
to this audience
that you're talking to,
especially the young audience,
and educate them on how
to cook these foods.
And showing them a raw piece of
cauliflower with crushed ice,
it's just so rank.
And it's so far from making
these things appealing,
and if we don't make them
appealing, we'll never do them.
And we're already doing
the burgers and the pizzas,
and 27% of the country say
they get their five a day.
So god knows how many people
are getting their ten a day.
And it's just I find it
frustrating, because yeah--
go ahead, eat
everything and anything,
but also eat more
fruit and vegetables,
and find a way to do that.
And if you keep, I've said, if
you vilify people for doing,
that just seems so ridiculous,
especially in light
of having an obesity crisis.
And I think it's a great
show, but we celebrate things
like the bake-off
which seems ironic.
We need to celebrate both
sides, and if we don't celebrate
both sides, people
are never going
to get to that middle ground
that they need to get to.
Like it's always going
to be a bit one-sided.
AUDIENCE: It's great
to see you be so
passionate about healthy food.
I have a question on
recipe development.
So how do you come
up with recipes,
do you pick like an
ingredient, and go off that.
Or do you focus on like a
category, like salads, you
have a lot of salad.
But you know what I mean?
ELLA MILLS: Yes,
and it normally is
based around an ingredient,
or a couple of ingredients,
and trying to find new and
interesting ways to do that.
I definitely find that--
I think because most online
people used "Deliciously Ella"
for quite simple, easy,
Monday night recipes, things
like that.
And so there's
definitely certain things
that people seem to really want,
and likewise, with our delis,
like sometimes you're
trying to introduce,
even things like beetroot,
they do not sell.
Everyone wants broccoli
and sweet potatoes
10 different ways.
And so I do try and
focus on that a lot,
because I do notice that if
it's quite simple, courgettes,
broccoli, sweet corn,
courgettes, things that people
are quite familiar with
and comfortable with,
those like beans and chickpeas.
That's what people definitely
seem to connect to the best,
so I really mostly
just focus on trying
to take those simple
things, and come up
with new and interesting
ways of doing them.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thank you so much for
being so open, and honest,
and down-to-earth
about everything.
It's been a real pleasure
listening to you talk.
Obviously you've
become catapulted
into sort of a business leader
position very, very quickly.
I wondered if you could
speak a little bit
to how you found that
process of learning
to be at the head of
a group of people,
and getting them on
board with your mission,
and keeping them on board.
And I guess, what your biggest
leadership learning has been,
across this time?
ELLA MILLS: Yeah,
totally, honestly, I
could not have
done without Matt.
I really-- I think
people can say that like,
oh it's so self-deprecating.
Like I could not have
done it without him.
It never worked in
anyone else's company,
because I got sick when
I was at university,
so I really did not
know what I was doing.
And so I've learned so much
from him, and working with him,
and seeing how he
manages people,
which is a lot better
than how I manage people.
100%.
I'm quite scattered, I'm
quite all over the place,
and he's very
thorough and diligent.
But I find it really
hard, and also I
felt like such an imposter
when people were like--
they kind of put you
up on this pedestal.
Like wow, OK, I really
don't know how I got there.
People are like healthy living
guru, and I'm like, oh my gosh,
I'm not a guru.
Then people are like, oh we
want you to come and talk here,
and you can come and talk here.
Yeah, like a business leader.
And I'm like, oh
gosh, I just started
cooking in my mom's kitchen.
I never-- because
I never set out
with intention of doing that,
I found it quite overwhelming,
to be honest.
I was quite embarrassed, I
would decline everything.
And then Matt started seeing
what I was [INAUDIBLE],
and he was like, why are
you saying no to this?
And I was like, I'm
really embarrassed,
I don't think I should go.
And he'd get so angry with me.
He was like, you're gonna
go, and I was like no.
And it was just
purely embarrassment,
because I would go in
somewhere, and I'd be like,
I shouldn't be here,
everyone else should be here,
I haven't earned my
place to be here.
Which I think I've got
better at slowly, but surely.
And I think, honestly, my
biggest thing is that I could
not have done it without a
partner, I really couldn't.
I did not have the
confidence to do it,
and I think that takes quite
a lot for me to admit that,
because I want to
pretend that I would.
But I don't think
that I would have.
And I think-- from my learnings,
that I have so much respect
for anybody who has the
confidence and ability
to do it on their own.
But for me, being able
to share it, I think
has made me a lot better.
And also having someone to
share the pressure with,
it's been / absolutely amazing.
But I think our biggest thing
has been trying to give people
a lot of autonomy.
And that's the same
thing of like realizing
where our strengths
are and where
our weaknesses are, and even
just in our areas of knowledge.
And so when we hire someone,
trying to give them the space
to run with what they're
doing, and run their team,
and run their budget.
And obviously we're
very close with them,
interact with them a
lot, and understand
everything that's going on.
But also just respect
them and their knowledge,
and not try to
micromanage everything,
even though-- especially
when getting started,
when we were so keen to know
anything and everything 24
hours a day.
But just respecting them.
You know the best people need
a bit of space to be the best,
I think so often.
And that they have
areas and knowledge,
you just got to trust them.
So that was really
important for us.
SPEAKER 1: Anymore
questions from anybody?
No?
Ella, thank you so you
much for coming in.
It's been an absolute pleasure,
we've thoroughly enjoyed it.
Ella's recipes are
going to be cooked
in the cafe on the fourth
floor, and we've also
got all of her books
outside being sold.
So just around on
the left-hand side.
Thank you very much.
ELLA MILLS: Thank
you guys for coming.
[APPLAUSE]